hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge des megaprojekts und
heute bin ich wieder in einem guten
alten gespannen und zwar zusammen mit
dem kongress über steuern
jan bist hier sehe ich hier gerade auch
ich gehe jetzt erstmal fed auf den
server drauf connect to megaprojekt
connect für megaprojekte stunde der
flachen witzel angenommen ja wir wissen
warum sagen wir wissen warum und jochen
pickel auf der stelle
du ich auch dass wir gestern mittag war
da noch nicht da oben
gestern mittag war gestern abend auf
einmal dinge nicht aus
linke auch direkt meine query builder
hier anders geht weiter
bei mir hat es gerade voll ich öffne
eine kiste die ba braucht erstmal jahre
bis da drin als die brd ich bin ich bin
in der kiste drin aber ich fliege mal
kurz du dir über ich habe übrigens weg
gebe die kräfte packten viele das habe
ich ja auch drin
ja komm mal kurz raus spitze das sieht
auf jeden fall ist die geilste was macht
meine curry da die arbeitet sich am
wasser bund wolltest du noch
glasscheiben um seinen turm rummachen
oder willst einfach so lassen
da mach ich auf jeden fall noch glas
wein blumen aber das wenig gekommen ich
wollte in dieser folge ein paar user
meinungen in der füllung bringe ich auch
ich habe nämlich ein paar screenshots
gemacht dass sie das mache ich lieber
eine einzelfolgen zusammen aufnimmt
damit hat ja okay du bewegst vernünftig
also das ding ist ich muss sowieso
diamanten suchen und dafür bietet es
eigentlich an das was mir angeboten dass
mir das mit auch so kann ein kleines
update sein müssten
ich fliege wieder weg ach so und zwar
habe ich bisher meine technik ab das
heißt ja bis die zentrifuge ex traktor
und den singulären kompressor also zu
sagen
die startmaschine aber alle sozusagen
auf dem höchsten stand ich war das bei
tim so heftig dass sie bei dem übel
style ausbilders dazu alles einfach
verbunden
ja das ist ich glaube der teleportiert
nicht lange aus der hölle in seinen
gangsta und befüllt sich damit alles ja
heftig heftig hat vor allem der alles
verbunden indem er einfach diese kabel
da gemacht hat diese röhren womit man
aus weiter transportieren kann das hatte
ich ja anfangs aber das hat bei mir
nicht ganz so funktioniert ich wollte
auf jeden fall ich habe neben meiner
teletrader und wieder zurück gemacht die
letzte luft geflogen ist und ich habe
jetzt ja auch ein msi der irgendwen habe
ich nicht an der uni verbio mfs uhr habe
ich nicht gehabt er steigert sich von
langsam weil die ganzen geräte natürlich
dauerhaft auf strom brauchen was hast du
denn für mich so keller
wolltet solar 11 ich habe auch eins oben
auf dem wasserturm noch
wie noch einfach so hast du noch
angefacht einfach weil es zu wenige gibt
das was vorteile leider ja ich wollte
vielleicht noch auf windkraft ein
bisschen setzen wenn nicht aber ich wenn
du was über wind gab diesen wird kann
ich dir alles darüber sagen dass ich
sehr gut übrigens sie dann wollte ich
aufnehme ich habe eigentlich zeit
ich habe auch zeit und ich habe jetzt
wenig im voraus produziert das heimteam
volkes relativ aktuell ja bei mir auch
im zwar nicht morgen aber so ziemlich
nah dran
und ja keine ahnung
hier können wir gerne also okay ich
mache auf jeden fall erstmal schwerter
aus welchem material am besten aus
welchen dann oh ja ich weiß habe ich an
dich denken willst easy wie mache ich
das wort ist übeltäter ich erwarte ich
schon mal da kann ja auch ihm selber
noch guck ich dachte es ist jetzt bald
nanosuit und so was alles zweimal hast
du das noch einen diamanten nur das
einzige heftige und ich habe keinen
diamanten das problem heißt nano nanos
aber vor allem saba mir wurde folgt die
muster aufladen wichtig mir wurde von
den usern als tipp gegeben dass ich mir
eine scanner machen soll
denn dieser scanner scannt einfach den
ganzen tank bzw 3 x 3 der schlecht ging
ich jetzt habe und 55 der beste den ich
gleich bauen
es kennt aber den bereich komplett unter
mir und wenn ein wert von ungefähr 90
ist dann soll ich einfach mit in meiner
meinung laser auch die höhe 16
runtergehen und einfach bis acht
untergraben und dorthin zu 90 diamanten
sei es muss gar nicht untergraben zu
gucken dass es sogar wollen wir
zumindest zugesagt
die christen die jagd
es ist mir ein diamanten wert nach kommt
es ist das beste schwert es geht niemals
kaputt und es macht glaube ich ihnen ja
stimmt es geht ja vor schaden das ist
das ist echt so ein vorteil ja ok
simon schuldet mir noch diamanten von
daher er schult mir einfach alles
vor allem dass das regt mich auch
einfach so auf dass jetzt auch einfach
nicht mehr antwortete freunde vielleicht
könnt ihr da nachhilfe und einfach mal
bei simon und das video schreiben mir
vielleicht beantworten könnte bzw
wie die waffen zurückgeben könnte es ist
einfach nur viel zu tun denke ich
einfach aber einfach das ihn daran
erinnert viel zu tun ist dann vergisst
man das mal aus dem kopf wie wenn man
nicht dran gedacht könnte ich mir
vorstellen
ja aber der geantwortet ich dachte der
straight ist hier stehen jedenfalls mehr
zurückgeben seitdem beispiel 1000
anderen aber hat nicht geantwortet
deswegen ist diese komisch aber ich
hoffe einfach dass ich in zukunft ein
items mit krieg und dann habe ich auch
wieder meine glück spitze kommt alles
andere und dann geht's wieder weiter
achso apropos david bailey verzaubern ja
wenn du mir etwas nicht ohne witz
du kannst du das wirklich das ding ist
einfach nur was fragen wollte mir wurde
einmal gesagt man kann zum beispiel auch
den mining laser verzaubern
aber es gibt nur mit büchern das würde
mich mal interessieren ob man wirklich
einen mining laser mit büchern
verzaubern kann weil was soll mir der
mining laser wirklich bringt mir wird
gesagt wenn man meine conne 1 das ist
meine meine heißt die neue die
highscores die das ist als wenn ich die
abbauen und in amboss rein tue und
umbenennen dann kriege ich die komplette
ladung die ich da bisher rein getan habe
zurück komplette solarwatt cells um so
was alles an was zurück ja man kriegt
hat das ist dann emails speichert sich
wenn es applaus es ist so wenn du
nämlich label nahm und dann ich hab
meine kev genannt einfach meinem einige
titel im programm
wenn ich die abbau und wieder hinsetzen
hat sie die energie die vom abbau sonst
verliert sie ja dass man die bestimmt
kann das sein
das stimmt also was ihr auf jeden fall
versuchen werde ich werde gleich mal mit
verbrechern zu dir kommen und einfach
hoffen dass ich dass ich mein linker
verzaubern kann meine diamond drill weil
denke ich der nie kaputt das wäre echt
geil nach dem effizienz verzaubern
könnte zum beispiel habe ich glaub mein
glück hat es nicht verzaubern oder ich
habe unendlichkeit meinst du auch mal
wohl mir gesagt also nicht direkt aber
würde bei dir war einfach auch ich hatte
den bogen mit unendlichkeit 1 und den
habe ich immer verloren durch simon das
heißt eigentlich schuldet der mir so
locker 50 level auch noch also ich habe
ein buch mit unendlichkeit 1 hatte ich
ja auch ich dann auf dem boden gepackt
und jetzt ist er bemerkt man das
wirklich zu auch auf das einfach am ende
hast du zufällig ein leder
ganz kurz meine kiste ich finde meine
bücher das gar nicht so viele bücher
nicht einhalten stellt bücher
ich habe aber noch 16 2/3 zweieinhalb
steckte also sack mit traden will ich
einzelne bücher schenken
nach der zuwendung mehrere stacks welt
vertreten ich will nur wirklich ich will
um wirklich gucken dass ich probeweise
mal drei bücher mittlerweile zehn
verzaubern und dann gucke ob überhaupt
eine verzauberte möglich auf meine will
ich will da noch keine großartigen
aktion starten nicht kommt mir vorbei
ich komme vorbei ast absägen scheider
drauf zu tun herrlich haben skater die
liegen hier unten übrigens darüber
kommen müssen nein hier hier hier
hallo haben ein hässliches gesicht alter
war sehen aus wie herkules schaltwippen
hinterm zaun viele kisten hast du bitte
dass er krank
ich brauche auf jeden fall zu mampfen
wollten ja erst los als ich pack mal
eben hier neben
den bildschirm manchmal so ein paar
tipps von euch an freunde effizienz 280
bekommen das schon fantastisch und
schutzwall und schutz 1 läuft übrigens
was bringt ein jetpack ist also backpack
habe ich wenn du betclic hass und zb die
elektrik ranch dann kannst du eine modus
aktivieren
derweil sonst mit elektrik rangers die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass zu 80 prozent
normal abgebaut wird und die 20 prozent
kaputt geht wenn du aber diesen mega
modus aktiviert
doch das 10.000 energie für abbauen das
ist halt den weg oder leppek das
verbesserte und nun bitte noch nicht
oder wenn man mal früh schlafen da kann
man nicht
es geht ich kann mein essen sie als
zweiter zaubern
das ist normal effizienz der schneller
ist
alter und der diamond drill da ist ja
aber da ist ja nicht ganz
echt nicht gedacht okay als freunde wir
begeben uns zuerst mal noch eine kleine
reise und sie bei bestimmten koordinaten
die wir die kommentare geschrieben
werden
so darum welche feature ich hab's
gesehen jetzt zeig ich mal wo die dias
liegen laut los da bin ich wohl schon
mal her gelaufen und da habe ich wohl
was vergessen oder so meinten die wbg
das 800 ach so und ich nehme ein ketzer
natürlich mit denn ich habe wie gesagt
im creative modus mal getestet ob ich
tatsächlich was wie rocky bienen oder so
was ist hier gibt im kreis habe ich sie
nicht gefunden also als ich das getestet
habe bei mir auf screen aber wenn ich
habe tolle fans gegangen da gab es die
idee entspannen da gibt es einen
bienenstock von und die hab ich mal ganz
kurz zur frage mein schwert geht die
ganze zeit wenn ich rechts zurück und
dann wenn du richtig machst dann blinkt
das soll dieses namens rock ja zu lästig
meisterwerk du musst wenn du es
aktiviert dann vergleicht das ganze zeit
energie es hat nur noch die hälfte der
energie obwohl ich das gerade nur ganz
kurz aktiviert hatte
fahrt mal muss das aktivieren wenn ich
damit schlag oder wie also wenn du wenn
du einmal muss schlägt ich weiß das
glaube ich wie ein stopp oder wie
normales schwert oder so aber wenn es
aktiviert oder sondern chris passt pro
sekunde energie und auch bei jedem
schlag aber dann zieht es aber mal so
viel herz und einem schlag ab wer ohne
dass sie jetzt gerichtlich voll unnötig
dass wir das gemacht habe dass das ist
übel schnell alle man das ganze angab
wahrscheinlich nur ja
809 fliegen das ist jetzt aber viel dass
der scanner nicht von meinem bett pack
geladen wird
wie das ist natürlich viel ich habe hier
ein scanner welcher eigentlich geladen
werden müsste und wieso habe ich ja
keine wegpunkte eigentlich irgendwie
lassen sich immer meine wegpunkte weil
es auch da muss wieder zurücklaufen was
hat ja richtig viel energie gekostet und
ich hab doch umwelt pack ganz ganz
eigenartig also irgendwie ist das alles
hier nicht so ganz großer wie ihr das
seht hier soll gut sein hier ist gar
nichts man freunde ihr habt keinen plan
vom leben nicht widerstehen läuft nix
nix
das kann aber nicht sein
der uv scanner war eigentlich im bett
pack hat ob irgendetwas benutzt wie den
drei mitgliedern liegt dass ich wieder
auf walthert gespeichert jahr 60.000
energie - 115 801 und höhe 68 ist nix
freunde was laberst du wenn ihr mich
verarschen wollen dich nicht witzig
so der faust gesehen wir machen ein
minimales plus
obwohl unsere hier geht unser gesamtes
grundstück auseinanderfällt nicht mal
mehr energie für meinen job machen egal
ob energie mehr gibt es nicht eine
möglichkeit dass ich irgendwie unendlich
energie immer habe wasserkraftwerk
unterwegs das männerteam kann low
voltage solar helm red back beide low
voltage solar helm kann import auf den
weg und schon das ende des liedes und
sobald das spiel mein ingrid benutzer
fließt die energie aber der legt sich
direkt vom bett bike auf das bett berg
lädt sich auf dem dings auf
ich glaube die meisten einfach meinen
kommentaren diesen komischen turm aber
da war ich ja schon mal ein bisschen
anders schon drin so wenn ich jetzt
gleich irgendwo man mobbt see oder
sondern als wie muss dessen machen mit
dem schwert muss ich rechts zieht mit
rechts schlag oder wie nine aktiviert
das ein rechtsklick und stieg dann zum
mit linksklick muss richtig gedrückt
lassen oder einmal drei mal drauf legten
dann fängt das an zu blinken wenn das
bringt ist das an natürlich das ja
nonstop energie ich nehme jetzt einfach
mal hier meinen low voltage ola ray mit
komm mal zu hause weniger energie aber
irgendwie scheint das budget sein dass
der scanner sich nicht auf lädt also ich
denke ich werde noch mal auf windenergie
ein bisschen umsetzen zum schwingen
bringt dadurch wächst drin sind bei dir
die wolken gut oder sind die wolken so
eckig sind gut aber es gibt auch ein
update paytv dass auch drauf ich hab das
feature bieten drauf also ich habe
gewonnen so ausständig sind im
hintergrunde wölkchen ja ja die würde
ich am liebsten auch mal ganz gern sehen
aber die sehen ich weiß ich hab nur
diese sequenz aus wenn in der pampa auf
einmal steht ein haus erwarten einen
sagen schon wieder und meine wegpunkte
einfach weckt aber ich hab keinen punkt
mehr
es kann nicht sein
ist eine runde mitleid für habe ich
irgendwo aus albstadt gestellt ich hatte
ja die übelste panik alten server
gegangen bin dann reagiere ich auf
einmal meinen wegpunkt uns alles da war
überall nächste realisiere ich geändert
und dann wirklich einiges klar deswegen
ja deswegen aber die ganzen leute sind
wundert mich schon
das allerdings mit einem wegpunkt zu tun
wenn sie anders sprechen doch alpi mäßig
geht voran indien in der nähe oder
könnte sein also ich hab jetzt keine
mehr
warte ich habe auch keine mehrere riesig
gerade das heißt findet nunmehr zurück
welt so schnell wie ich hab doch
wegpunkte sowie bäume waren und wo sie
höhlen wann wo ich noch ein wort ergab
das ganze in der conficker weinstein und
guck mal hier was haben wir hier sind
jetzt kommen die man wenn man ausleihen
weil ich keine energie hat abgesperrt
also wie gesagt 65 ich warte bis
wirklich auf den wert der über 80 ist
wurde mir gesagt da soll ich dann graben
aber das kann braucht so schnell energie
das finde ich bisher and recht vor allem
ich habe ja auch mein bett keck auf das
leder irgendwie keine freuen wir testen
jetzt mal den namen november sollte
eigentlich alles wandert sein
ich bin bisher unzufrieden was dieses
denn japan geht was meinst du mit
scanner was macht gebaut er wie gesagt
ich hab's gern aber ich wechsle und er
sagt mirror value investoren also print
web und röcke ist 58 und da hat mir ein
user und liste geschickt was zum
beispiel die pink diamantring beispiel
fünf punkte
wenn man davon ausgeht je höher die
anzahl ist desto wahrscheinlicher ist es
dass diamanten und nur so eine hohe
anzahl mit diamanten erreichen kann ist
echt alles wandert alter ist das krass
ich muss halt immer auf demokraten dass
er kommt dann aktiviert es kurzzeitig zu
einer anni diese extra zum ich sie
brauche schon noch zwei schläge wirklich
bewegt aber es ist unglaublich energie
verbrauchen als ich hab es bei der
jockey teilung
die ganze zeit vor dem machen.foto
realisieren erschießt mich ja nciht werk
ist ja auch schon alles ich kann doch
nicht wegfliegen
so wollte ich so lange hier kommen läuft
nicht wirklich auf ein wert der endlich
mal 80 an zeigt das kann ich sagen ihr
müsst noch überall möglich diamanten
seien
natürlich haben auch zinn und eisen
irgendwelche wert haben wenn die meinen
wir wenn irgendwie über 80 ist dann soll
ich da abbauen so hier und jetzt erst
mal wieder alles ausgeleuchtet dann kann
der gustav ihr hätte noch weiter
durchfahren 78 79 fängt doch machen
zurzeit mit 84 ja kein dinge theodor 84
punkte das heißt hier müssten laut die
usern zu 90 prozent von seinen einem
fünf mal fünf kästchen wie jetzt ich
hab' das aber nicht so richtig verstehen
werden wir ausgegeben wurde ist 85
das heißt man das jetpack rein und das
heißt in einem fünf mal fünf radius um
mich rum also ecke zwei blöcke von mir
weit weg sollen fünf gäste mussten
denken da ist der wert von mir bis ganz
nach unten
85 und zb diamanten bringt fünf punkte
eisen 2.17 ein punkt körper zwei punkte
redstone zwei punkte und so wenig punkte
und diamant bedingt sie viele punkt das
heißt wenn 85 punkte sind es entweder
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass mega viel
eisen beispiel drin sind oder einfach
diamanten weil sie die punktzahl
exorbitant nach oben ziehen lassen das
ist gut und ich hab auch verdammt ich
habe
mit dem jetpack mit dem mining laser ich
gehe einfach schnell auf die höhe
ich brauche immer weise keine kohle mit
körperlich bin ich denn gleichzeitig
zeigt er wie sein traum ist schneller
und mit dem einen laser bin jetzt wieder
auf der höhe alter falter sind das viele
sexy junge junge
das an blogger 70 6 cobblestone hier
alter ist das immer mal 66 locker fast
allen gefunden alter adam kannst du dich
schlafen legen oder bistum oder pampa
ich begann ist ja aber ich bin so weit
weg gerade und ja ich kann mich kurz
schlafen da müsstest du allerdings kurz
vom server geändert
ja mach ich auch nicht ich einen kurzen
weg punkt a so und dann sage ich war
kurz und sagt wenn du fertig geschlafen
hast
oh ja ok wartet auf den weg zu meinem
bett
ich liege in meinem bett mit dem shader
mit so unverschämt schnell dunkel ich
sie gar nicht mehr sie gar nix mach dir
eine cashback dies fast so groß wie eine
doppelspitze uns alle items reinstopfen
dank an raster 99 98 games world media
du darfst die items nicht mit shift aus
dem ofen holen sonst kriegst du keiner
xp das habe ich schon getestet verarsche
bei fiete wies funktioniert das nicht
ich hort o limone shift raus und ich
trotzdem keine erfahrung
hey conny wenn du mal sand brauchst du
einfach koppel in may straight up das
ist gut zu wissen dann meist dass jetzt
mehr leute die kacke ist dass das rad
dreht sich ja gar nicht auf hey
der scanner ist irgendwie komisch aber
so richtig der legt sich gar nicht
richtig auf dich hab jetzt ein
solarpanel reingepackt er legt sich da
auch nicht auf das irgendwie ganz ganz
eigenartig verstehe ich nicht ich habe
einfach mal viel zu viel cobblestone
dass ich noch alles verarbeiten
weiß gleich zwischen welcher höhe können
diamanten auftreten 0 und darf jetzt
dann glaube ich könnte auch 16 sein oder
weiß nicht ich baue mir kurz noch ein
bisschen holz ab damit wir wenigstens
zwei fackeln oder so machen kann noch
einige
aber genau das haben sie gesagt ich habe
hier so viele sachen ich kann mir schon
wieder neuen diamanten machen mit dem
halter wurde scania
so also sagt minimale ebene 11 diamanten
ist 12 1 hat die ganze zeit bis er den
ton relativ leute ich hoffmann hat sich
trotzdem ausreichend gefährt und macht
ihr einfach drum bei käfern so also
erstens ist hier erde auf der diamant
dass dingert mich verarscht kann man aus
sand irgendwie kohle machen
müssen gucken ob mit dem buggy stein mit
dem mixer stein was geht nie um wichtig
also ich habe jetzt hier bin jetzt die
richtigen höhe diamanten sehe ich nicht
obst bis zum aus aber die ansicht kriege
ich kohle
also ich sag mal so hier sind schon
diverse ärzte jetzt bilden aber das sind
keine diamanten
jedes kritik auch nicht hin nein nein
nein nein das ist sehr uncool
ja ich glaub mal ganz kurz meine sachen
erfolg kacke alter wollte mir so eine
mühe gegeben
hier ist tatsächlich nur witze machen
jetzt normalen solar helm kommen die man
gibt mir die ganze sache nicht zurück
hammer echt geil alter tipp ist ja mal
zucker oder auch nicht medium voltage
solaren müssen wenn man über nacht wird
sie ein helm machen
okay zum lade ich hoffe wirklich also
das ist einfach nur unglaublich das war
mal lvb marie das transformer cable kuba
zweimal und ich sehe hier nicht haben
kompatibel wir keine kisten
zu wenig noch eine kiste so wo fett war
normal häufigsten diamanten wie oft noch
83 jetzt hier wieder eine angenehme
stelle online da brauche ich da so viele
sachen für ich brauche dich braucht man
erst mal angeschossen acht generatoren
ich mache mir jetzt noch keinen die man
sich selbst geben
ich habe hauptsächlich admin schacht
gefunden
aber ich will eigentlich gar nicht
erforschen
man regt mich das auf dass meine ganzen
sachen einfach weg sind jetzt habe ich
mich verlaufen wenn ich zum gustav
werden
scheisse scheisse bitten ich bitte dich
bitte nicht ich bin der größte könner
dienst gibt nein ich bin so dumm meine
goldküste ist verschwunden weil ich die
ganze zeit nicht erstaunt sein wieviel
die dieses teure goldkette zu machen ja
aber da rausgeholt und ich habe kein
gold kann sie aus eisen machen gold
ehrlich mit miriam stein ist
gesellschaft braucht zwar viel eisen
aber es geht wie viel eisen braucht man
denn acht verein gold ein golderz lion
gold
warum es ist ein undankbares geschäft
jetzt mein verrottete fleisch nur so gar
nichts zu essen wir sind ja ich presse
ganz einfach das fleisch genauso wie im
echten leben wie immer mehr hunger wenn
er fordert das fleisch ist dann geht es
über hunger ja ich habe noch nie
verstanden dass mit dem hunger
funktioniert du kriegst du einen die
bafin rotes fleisch ist dass du hunger
hast und ja und das heißt du kriegst du
schnell wieder hunger und muss ich mal
wieder was essen wenn ihr blut ist oder
so kriegst du den dieb auch nicht
deswegen hält das wir ja weiter
fünf diamanten
das kam ganz geil alter das kam ganz
wichtig ein kult
das ist echt einschaltung von dankbares
geschäfte ich habe die jungs alles
scheißegal
das ist ein richtig undankbares geschäft
soll jetzt 40 gold daraus bekommen wow
wow ich mache hier 40 gold ich brauche
das so fiel nicht doch nein
doch ich mache mir zehn diamanten alter
das habe ich auch gemacht das ist
wirklich so und damit diesen scanner
macht und sein
ganz ehrlich ich hoffe einfach dass ich
durch diese paar klicks wenigstens jetzt
noch mal die am ende kommt und clymer
oder zwei mal kann ich nur
einmal kann ich noch klicken ist es über
80 34 muss ich wieder zurück zum base
also das ding ist mit dem ding darf man
offenbar nicht weit weg von der base
denn sonst gibt ist das ein ufo scanner
ein eau d scanner oder ein entity
scanner entities ach so nennt es kann da
kenne ich nicht
body scanner ist die vorform von uv
scanner also der ods kenner der scannt
ein drei mal drei bereich das heißt
antwort der wert hoch ist er wenn er
richtig hoch ist kann sie sicher sein
dass banker müssen diamanten seien aber
das könnte einen kleinen bereich und
dementsprechend kostet ihr alles viel
energie 250 pro einmal nutzen kloster
und stadt ist leicht gold gebe lauf und
d scanner pornos auf jeden fall besser
man sagt es auch relativ leicht
das genom von einfach ja also ist auch
überholt energien ergibt sich schnell
weg ist doch haltbarkeit oder also alles
ist unendlich haltbar klar aber es war
zwar eine 10.000 energie der stadt
gerade die pille tief 27
bei einem scanner dem scanner sprichst
du scanner habe ich doch das steht die
mobility 26 von 27
man kann ja schon vorbei da wird ja was
einst sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
bleibt geil macht's gut